-Our next guests are
the Emmy-nominated creators,
writers, and stars
of the critically acclaimed
series "PEN15."
The show's final episodes
are streaming on Hulu.
Let's take a look.
-Oh, no.
This is why I got braces.
Are you kidding me?
-I mean, honestly,
I like you better that way.
-With a snaggle?
I'm gonna have
to get my braces back on.
-You still there?
-Hi, yeah.
-Turn on the radio to HOT 106.7.
-Wha-- Okay.
Um, Anna.
Anna, he just said
put the radio on.
Put it on, on 106.7.
Did he get you concert tickets?
-I don't know.
-Please welcome back to the show
our friends
Anna Konkle and Maya Erskine.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, you guys!
-Thank you!
-Congratulations on the show.
-And I also want to say
congratulations on the fact
that you both had babies
in this past year.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I would imagine --
I'm already insanely jealous
of the fact
that you're best friends
who co-created a show together.
It must have been really nice
to have kids
within two months of each other.
Was that a fun time?
I mean, I know
it's not necessarily a fun time,
but was it made more fun?
-Up all night, never sleeping.
-Haven't slept for eight months,
but, yeah, it's been great.
It's been so helpful to have
each other go through it,
'cause it's so hard.
-It was weird
learning about lactating,
in general.
-Uh-huh.
-And at home during COVID,
'cause I didn't have
to deal with going out
and learning about,
like, pads and the bras.
I'm sure you really want
to talk about this.
-Well, no, I mean, I think,
having gone through it,
the body does not know
that you're out in public.
-It does not.
I have learned.
And, actually, I think I told --
We were out to dinner,
and it was one of
the first dinners out.
I was feeling like a human being
with our daughter
and my partner.
And I'm feeling good about
myself, and we're leaving,
and Aaron Paul is there,
and he starts talking to us
about our daughter,
and he was really, really sweet.
I'm like, "Yeah, we're having
a great time here."
And we leave, and I realize
that my white shirt
has fully wet spot
and my nipple is just there.
[ Laughter ]
Humiliating.
-Well, I'm wondering
why Aaron Paul was trying so
hard to extend the conversation.
-Oh, God!
[ Laughter ]
-I'm sorry, Aaron Paul.
I'm sorry.
-So, the brilliant conceit
of this show is you, as adults,
have been playing yourselves
as 13-year-olds.
Now that you have children,
have you thought about the fact
that this might be a document
to one day show them?
-I really don't think my son's
gonna want to watch this,
especially 'cause there
are episodes of me
doing things like --
-Masturbating.
Thank you, Anna.
[ Laughter ]
And I don't know if I can say --
I don't want to give away,
but there are other bases
that I get to past kissing.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't want him to see that,
but I think it could be
a good conversation starter,
maybe, you know?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
I do think it's interesting
because it's like --
it would be totally fine for,
like, a mom to explain
to her son
about masturbating
but probably best not to, like,
"Let me show you."
-"Let me show you how I did it
at your age."
-Yeah, "And don't worry.
A lot of people
have seen your mom doing this.
Don't worry.
This was on TV."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
-You guys always borrow
from your regular life
and your experience
and your history
and things you remember
about being
that really awkward age.
I always am desperate
to know what, from the show,
in recent seasons
is true to your life.
-I mean, I would say
like 80% is probably true.
There's something this season
where Maya gets, like,
yellow-tinted glasses.
-Here.
We have a photo
of the yellow-tint glasses.
-Very hot.
-Which look really cool,
but, actually, I was diagnosed
with what's called
Irlen Syndrome.
I don't know if any of you
have it here.
But it basically --
First, I was told I have ADD,
so, you know, the doctor gave me
a prescription for Ritalin,
and then he was like,
"You get extended time
on testing for SATs,"
and I was like, "Great.
I definitely have ADD."
[ Laughter ]
And then he was like,
"How do you feel about
fluorescent lights?"
And I was like, "I don't feel
good about -- I don't like them.
They don't feel good.
Why? Why?"
And he's like,
"Because these glasses.
Like, these glasses
will help you focus better,
and you can learn better."
And I wasn't that convinced
because they were those,
and, basically,
he showed me a picture
of Haley Joel Osment
on the red carpet wearing, like,
yellow-tinted glasses,
and he was like,
"He has Irlen Syndrome,
and so you should wear them."
So I did.
Fast-forward --
That convinced me.
We're friends now.
-You and Haley?
-Yeah, he was like,
"I never had Irlen Syndrome.
That was just me
on the red carpet.
-That was fashion.
-Yeah. That was fashion.
Yeah.
-I like that you thought
that diagnosis was exciting
to you because --
-It was, yeah.
-But you were excited
about getting braces.
-Yeah.
-In real life.
-Yes, in fifth grade.
Fourth grade, actually,
I knew I was gonna have
to get braces
'cause my teeth were crazy.
And so, yeah, my orthodontist
said, "Okay.
We could do it now,"
and I had them for two years.
I got them off, and then
one tooth just went rogue.
-Uh-huh.
-And I also had that
appliance thing that, like,
expanded the top of your --
How is that legal?
-Yeah.
-That hurt.
And so, yeah.
So then I got the braces off,
and the tooth came off --
I mean, out.
Basically off.
And wearing the retainer
didn't work,
and so eventually --
Actually, my orthodontist died.
[ Audience groans ]
I know.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
But again...
He wasn't maybe
great at his job.
[ Laughter ]
Just saying.
Rest in peace.
-I'm crying. I'm crying.
-Yeah.
-No.
And then the new orthodontist
was like, "You messed up."
[ Laughter ]
And then said, "You need braces
for another two years."
-Really?
So you got them back on.
I mean, I had braces for maybe
five years, start to finish,
but at least I never had
that moment where they came off
and I thought
I was out of the woods.
-Right.
-That's really hard.
-That's dark.
-But five years is a long time.
-Yeah, mine were --
mine were rough.
I think we just
forgot to go back.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-I think one day, like,
we just got super used to them,
and then, one day,
my dad was like, "Hold on."
[ Laughter ]
"You're about to go to college."
Hey, you guys write a lot
about your relationships
with your mother --
your mothers this season.
Your mother -- Your actual
mother plays your mother.
-She does.
-Immediate star.
Is she aware?
-Oh, she's aware, yeah.
-Yeah.
-She's taking interviews,
she's doing, you know --
she's getting other auditions.
She's using my agents.
I think they're hers now.
I'm not sure.
But, yeah, she's great.
-What would she be like
if she had joined us
on the couch today?
-Oh, yeah, she should be here.
-I know.
She would roast me.
She would definitely burn me
if she was sitting
right next to me.
I don't think it would be --
-Like, soft burns?
-The thing is, she's Japanese,
so it's just very much
part of that culture to, like,
downplay everything.
Like, "Don't look
at my daughter, please.
Like, she has short legs.
Like, don't look at her."
You know, like, it's very --
That has happened.
-I love your legs.
-But she says it's, like,
a false modesty
'cause she actually feels
very proud about her daughter,
but she doesn't want to, like,
say that out loud to everyone.
She doesn't want it
to seem too perfect.
-I like that your mom and you,
I guess, to some degree,
almost fell for or did fall for
a scam modeling agency?
-Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, because we lived
outside of Boston
in a little suburb,
and so the dream was,
you go in the city,
and you're gonna be discovered.
And I thought that happened
in Boston.
Someone stopped me.
I'm 5'8",
so I think that was
the only reason in retrospect.
And they were like,
"Are you a model?"
Clearly not a model.
And I was like,
"No, but I could be."
-They were like,
"You look like --
We don't say this all the time.
You look like
you've had braces twice."
[ Laughter ]
"That's how good
your teeth are."
-Yes. Yes.
[ Laughter ]
And this woman gave me a card,
and I went to a hotel room --
with my mom --
-Okay.
-Maybe a month later.
-I mean, in this day and age,
that's a huge -- yeah.
-Yeah, yeah.
No.
And, yeah, they were like,
"It's gonna be $7,000
for you to model.
We have to get pictures,"
and my mom was sold.
And I was --
I actually ended up being like,
"I don't --
That doesn't feel right."
-Your mom was sold.
-And she was like,
"We have to do this."
Meanwhile, I'm getting,
you know, consignment clothes.
But for some reason, she's like,
"Let's just spend it."
[ Laughter ]
-That's crazy.
-"Just do it."
It's really sweet, actually.
-You guys, I think, people --
it's safe to say
a lot of people are heartbroken
that you're closing this
thing up after three chapters,
but that was always your plan.
-Mm-hmm.
-Are you satisfied
with how it's all ending?
-I feel -- Yeah.
I feel really good about it.
I feel happy where we left
Maya and Anna's characters,
but it is sad, you know?
-It's bittersweet.
-Yeah.
-Well, congratulations.
It's such a beautiful, deeply
funny show, and it's so unique,
as unique as anything on TV.
So, thank you
for three incredible chapters.
You guys,
Anna Konkle, Maya Erskine.
The final episodes of "PEN15"
are streaming on Hulu.